we just got confirmation on three  specific apple products that are getting  ready to launch and ship very soon the  first of these three is of course the  new iphone se3 to me this just proves  that apple is only making this change to  market the buzzword 5g and to stop using  the a13 and put the a15 chip into more  products coming into india with two new  model numbers the air 5 will replace the  4 it will get the a15 just like the se  and with that 5g support to keep up with  the pack so what about the third and  final new product that was registered  and is now being tested in india with  verdict seems to be that this surprise  ipad is a replacement for the ninth  generation ipad that launched less than  five months ago if this is the case then  the budget ipad will also get the  redesigned treatment and have a modern  clean look with a likely price increase  to 399 dollars